it is January 31st 2023 and you're
watching the code report Beethoven once
said music can change the world but I
really hope this dude was wrong because
AI is getting pretty good at making its
own music this relaxing Jazz track
you're hearing in the background right
now isn't Kenny G but rather a five
minute AI generated jam session created
with a simple text prompt music is the
strongest form of magic it transcends
all language barriers yet humans are the
only creatures that create and enjoy it
with the exception of parrots of course
Google just released a paper called
music LM and it describes its Research
into generating music from a text prompt
it's basically a chat GPT or dolly for
music of all digital art forms music is
the most difficult to reproduce because
it takes place over a specific temporal
space consisting of thousands of tokens
and needs to invoke human emotions
that's why every morning I listen to Eye
of the Tiger to get fired up before
writing any JavaScript code but
listening to the same song over and over
again gets boring let's find out if AI
can generate new music for us on the Fly
this model was trained on a relatively
small data set of 5000 music samples
paired with a text description and you
can access this data on kaggle before we
talk about it though you should know
that there's another groundbreaking text
and music project out there called
refusion it works like a text to image
generator except that it creates
spectrograms which are then converted to
audio and actually sound like coherent
music that's pretty cool but music LM
takes a completely different approach
that doesn't rely on diffusion music LM
is a pure audio model which relies on
two different types of tokens semantic
tokens capture details like Melody and
Rhythm while acoustic tokens from
Soundstream capture things like the
recording conditions of the track these
tokens are combined then decoded into a
high fidelity audio track but we have a
prompt for the soundtrack of an arcade
game
if that were playing in the background
of a retro video game I'd have no idea
it was AI generated but now let's try
something a little more difficult A
hip-hop track with vocals
[Music]
I wouldn't say it's a Bop but it's not
terrible either if you listen closely to
the lyrics they're just nonsense words
but they sound good if I were faded at
the club I could easily bust a Groove to
this show what's really amazing about
music ml though is Melody conditioning
or in other words you can generate music
that respects a text prompt while also
providing the actual Melody like if you
record yourself humming Beethoven's Ode
to Joy
you can then convert it to any style
like an opera singer or guitar solo
in addition they tested it on
descriptions of paintings and it does a
pretty good job of capturing the mood of
the paintings still nowhere near as
beautiful as what a talented human
musician could create
[Music]
but I think AI has the potential to
revolutionize music production in the
near future imagine a smart keyboard
with AI like this built in you play a
little Melody then it comes up with an
infinite number of possible arrangements
with different sounds instruments and
styles instead of actually composing and
producing music but we'll just guide the
AI in the right direction until the
track is bumping with continuation and
voice cloning you could even bring
Michael Jackson and Kurt Cobain back to
sing a duet on your track you could then
use chat GPT to write the perfect lyrics
and if you're a DJ you could use Vision
AI to capture the mood on people's faces
in the crowd and generate music on the
Fly that suits them perfectly this has
been the code report thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one